bom dia gente tudo bem hoje eu tô aqui
pra falar pra vocês sobre como a
inteligência artificial está
transformando a internet cada vez mais
humana
mas antes de falar de inteligência
artificial eu gostaria de trazer o
contexto histórico tecnológico de três
grandes revoluções que a gente teve até
hoje onde a primeira delas foi a
revolução agrícola onde começou se a
colocar alguns instrumentos de
tecnologia dentro do processo da
agricultura a segunda revolução
industrial que todo mundo sabe que mudou
o jeito como eles consomem os produtos
uma das principais tecnologias que foi
utilizado nessa época foram as máquinas
a vapor ea terceira e mais recente que
eu acho que todos nós estamos
participando de alguma forma é a
revolução digital ou a internet essa sim
mudou radicalmente a forma de como a
gente consome produtos de como a gente
se relaciona de como a gente passou
principalmente consumir conteúdo a
partir do boom das redes sociais e dos e
commerces nós começamos a ter acesso a
diversos tipos de dado isso tornou
internet previsível e trafegável ou seja
a gente pode rastrear tudo está na
internet
mas segundo alguns estudos e alguns
estudiosos entre eles recusam que é um
dos futuristas mas a famosos e
importantes do mundo
nós estamos prestes a ver três novas
grandes revoluções tecnológicas
a primeira delas é a biotecnologia que
basicamente é o processo de pegar a
matéria orgânica e através de algum veto
tecnológico alterar o comportamento
padrão dela
a segunda é a nanotecnologia que é pegar
uma matéria e alterar o processamento o
comportamento padrão dela através de
pesquisas tecnológica em dando escala ou
seja um nível muito atômico muito
pequeno ea terceira que a gente vai
explorar mais aqui é a robótica e
inteligência artificial e robótica
basicamente é pegar processos mecânicos
e automatizar seus processos de
inteligência artificial com vocês viram
no teste anterior que passou aqui no
vídeo é programar softwares e através de
técnicas de programação tentar deixar o
software mais inteligentes
a inteligência artificial tem diversas
áreas de atuação a partir da união de
algumas dessas competências
construir supercomputadores esses
supercomputadores basicamente simulam a
inteligência humana ou seja eles tentam
aprender e pensar como a gente com o
objetivo de tomar de tomar decisões
baseados nos humanos
a gente vai fazer e vai mostrar alguns
exemplos de como a gente está
interagindo hoje com essa inteligência
artificiais
a primeira coisa que a gente vai ver
aqui é basicamente a assistência das
escolhas
todos os dias nós somos obrigados a
fazer diversos tipos de escolhas na
internet sem a gente se dá conta agente
ativo na internet a gente vai atrás de
informações e traçar o nosso caminho o
que a gente vai fazer aqui simular um
processo de compra de um casaco ou
diferente dentro de um é como esse que
está plugado e uma inteligência
artificial
então dentro de si e commerce a primeira
coisa que ele faz é nos perguntar quando
e onde a gente quer usar esse casaco a
gente vai lá responde que a gente quer
usar em nova york no inverno
reparem a diferença do primeiro passo de
compra eu não estou indo atrás do
produto ele já me pergunta por que eu
quero fazer com o produto
a segunda coisa que ele me pergunta é
para que eu vou usar esse produto é que
eu vou usar um casaco então responda
aqui é pra correr ea terceira coisa e
última ele pergunta quem vai usar esse
casacos é um homem ou uma mulher
então a gente responde tinha um homem a
partir desses dois impulsos que eu dei
sobre o casaco e sobre quem vai vestir
ele ele fica processando e nos traz
algumas sugestões de compra essas
sugestões de compra não vem ao caso aqui
serve pra correr no inverno de nova york
não mas me parece que serve parecem que
são casacos que funcionam super bem para
correr no inverno
não sei se de nova york ou londres ou de
paris mas enfim eles parecem proteger do
frio que é o que importa
o que eu quis trazer aqui é justamente a
diferença do modelo de estruturação de
dados na hora da compra
quando a gente vai entrar no comércio
normal a gente fala nossa situação ea
nossa vontade ou seja eu quero comprar
um casaco para a corrida ou um
guarda-chuva maior para fazer esportes
isso não está errado porque a gente está
dizendo que a gente quer comprar um
casaco para fazer alguma coisa
só que o que faz toda a diferença nessa
situação
somente fator externo já o fator de eu
quero comprar um casaco para correr em
nova york no inverno porque comprar um
casaco para correr no inverno carioca é
muito diferente de comprar um casaco
para ocorrer no inverno de nova york
provavelmente o casaco de nova york tem
que ser muito mais quente do que o
casaco do inverno do carioca
como é que ele faz isso ele está plugado
ao supercomputador chamado a ibm watson
e supercomputador ele é cognitivo então
ele consegue aprender e processar
informações a fim de tomar decisões
muito parecida conosco assim como um
atendente me faria essa pergunta sim
sugerir algum tipo de casaco esse
computador tenta simular isso o impacto
disso nossas vidas na minha visão a
gente vai fazer um recorte tide dois
mercados basicamente que o mercado de
venda de produto e de marketing online
hoje na internet nós somos segmentados
de alguma forma seja produto por região
ou por interesse
isso nos parece que não faz tanto
sentido porque se eu vou no google e
procuro casaco para a corrida o casaco
para esportes
eu fico dez dias recebendo propagandas
de casaco tênis camiseta e diversos
tipos de produtos para o esporte e não o
casaco de corrida que eu quero usar para
correr no inverno de nova york
além do mais ele não pára de mandar as
notificações quando comprei já o casaco
ele continua oferecendo os tênis de
corrida e outros produtos derivados do
guarda-chuva esporte com esse tipo de
inteligência artificial a gente consegue
personalizar o atendimento das pessoas a
gente consegue saber exatamente qual o
produto elas querem e pra quê situação
específica elas querem e na minha visão
a internet cada vez mais está deixando
todos os produtos personalizados as
pessoas querem a personalização dos seus
produtos
ou seja se a gente continuar investindo
nessa propaganda e direcionando nossos
produtos de e commerce para segmentos
fixos e cruzamentos de dados básicos sem
colocar situações importantes
a gente não vai atingir o público a
gente espera provavelmente então quem
trabalha nessa área acredita que tem que
ficar ligado na ii a inteligência
artificial nos próximos tempos
e aí partindo para a educação que eu
acho que é um dos principais pilares da
sociedade e é por aí
o que nós todos estamos aqui a gente
está aqui para buscar conhecimento de
alguma forma o professor da universidade
de tecnologia da geórgia percebeu que o
grande problema dos cursos online e
engajamento dos alunos
os alunos tendem a se engajar pouco nos
cursos online com o passar do tempo
porque eles têm pouca assistência então
o cara vai lá e faz uma pergunta ou a
pergunta a demora para ser respondido se
ele tem uma dúvida poucas pessoas
conseguem responder e ajudar ele num
tempo hábil
sendo assim ele criou adil athirson que
a derrota não faz ela é um uma
inteligência artificial que fica
monitorando um fórum fórum de discussão
de um curso online
quando surge uma pergunta ela responde
como ela responde a essa pergunta ela
foi alimentada com 40 mil postagens com
perguntas e respostas mas como é que ela
sabe que ela está certa ela só pode
responder uma pergunta quando tem 97% de
che certeza que a resposta certa
como é que ela faz isso ela faz isso
porque ela consegue fazer uma análise
léxica das perguntas ou seja ela
cognitivamente entende o texto foi
detectado que as perguntas basicamente
elas repetem a gente consegue plaster
izar as perguntas mais ou menos a grande
diferença é como elas são escritas como
a gente escreve pergunta é que muda o
significado dela para o computador
se o computador começa a ler e entender
como a gente não faz mais sentido a
gente fazer um trabalho repetitivo
atualmente esse tipo de de fórum também
pode ser plugado supercomputadores como
o watson ou como outro tipo de
experiência que a gente vai ver que um
pouco mais na frente
o impacto disso educação a gente vê por
três pontos
o primeiro deles é justamente a educação
personalizada os espaços de aprendizagem
cada vez mais personalizados porque eu
posso aprender matemática de um jeito
típica de outro e filosofia de outro se
a gente começa a ter esse tipo de
interação em tempo real e começa a
entender de fato como as pessoas
aprendem a gente consegue medir
exatamente a performance dela dentro de
cada processo de aprendizado
o segundo ponto é justamente a
descentralização que é o condutor do
conteúdo para que seu principal e
opositor de conteúdo
consegui construir o conteúdo com os
outros participantes
isto há que se a gente conseguir ter
feedback instantâneo do que está
acontecendo do conteúdo e tempo real a
gente consegue conduzir o conteúdo para
um lado ou para outro
o terceiro ponto e na minha visão muito
importante são os educadores
eles passam a fazer um trabalho
repetitivo e segmentado e muito
previsível que por exemplo corrigir
provas ou ficar respondendo perguntas
repetidas
isso dá uma liberdade maior para
educadores começarem a fazer outras
coisas gerar mais conteúdo e estudar
outros métodos de aprendizado
na minha visão a educação pode escalar
da maneira que a gente nunca pôde
escalar a antes assim então se a gente
quiser atingir mais gente causam impacto
a educação essa tecnologia pode nos
ajudar bastante nisso
por fim chegamos a assistência da saúde
a saúde é outro pilar da sociedade que é
extremamente preocupante ea nível global
o hospital de londres abriu suas portas
para testar para fazer testes do
extremis extremos é um aplicativo que
ele está basicamente conectado um
supercomputador e super 40 computador
está conectado ao sistema do hospital
então ele consegue saber o que acontece
no hospital em tempo real
tenho um paciente e um leito ea pressão
dele é alterada de acordo com o padrão
que ele segue depressão
o aplicativo já recebe uma notificação
para os médicos ou para os enfermeiros
dizendo que teve uma alteração bem
drástica na pressão daquele paciente ou
se uma pessoa fazer um exame exame da
alterado também atualização acontece em
tempo real
a primeira amostragem que eles fizeram
foi com as pessoas que têm insuficiência
renal que causa cerca de 10 mil mortes
nos hospitais públicos de londres e
utilizando o aplicativo mais preventivo
eles perceberam que houve uma diminuição
de 25% das mortes por causa dessa doença
como é que isso acontece o extremo está
conectada de paiva que é tipo um ibm
watson do google é o computador
superinteligente tinha ouvido a
informações do motor de busca que a
gente usa todos os dias e para vocês
imaginam a cabeça a capacidade de
inteligência
o que esse cara tem o impacto disso a
sociedade
na nossa visão é muito grande é enorme
porque na saúde a gente geralmente é
muito responsiva a gente não é preditivo
o paciente ele sempre vai ao médico ou
vá ao hospital depois que alguma coisa
aconteceu
a gente não consegue evitar se a gente
conseguisse evitar as doenças
a nossa expectativa de vida
provavelmente a melhorar bastante e no
âmbito do médico também assim como
educador
ele deixa de fazer trabalhos são
repetitivos e segmentados e pode fazer
outras coisas que não são tão
repetitivas como buscar mais conteúdo se
especializar mais em algumas áreas à
saúde para escalar também precisa ter
essa tecnologia
esse tipo de tecnologia perto do que a
gente gasta e investe em saúde hoje ela
não é tão cara é muito acessível
eu acredito muito todas as atividades
todas vão ser impactadas por esse tipo
de tecnologia
por que por que hoje vários de nós fazem
tarefas segmentados lineares primitivas
extremamente simples e especialistas se
a gente deixar que essas tarefas
a gente vai ficar ali fazer outras
coisas a gente pode ser assistido por
essa inteligência artificiais com o
objetivo da gente melhorar nossa
qualidade de vida e trazer mais valor
agregado para os nossos negócios para as
nossas vidas
além do que a internet se torna
extremamente personalizada para cada
pessoa cada pessoa cria um ecossistema
único dela dentro do dos ecossistema a
gente pode ser extremamente radical que
trabalhar de uma forma que a gente nunca
trabalhou na internet está sendo
alimentado a gente deixa de ser linear
da segmentação a gente passa a ser
completamente exponencial e tem uma
série de escolhas
é por isso que eu acredito que a
inteligência artificial pode mudar o
mundo e impactar a educação ea saúde de
forma positiva a tecnologia que a gente
tem hoje evoluiu e não parece que o
mundo ficou pior
nos parece que o mundo está cada vez
ganhando mais se tivesse tipo de
tecnologia para 60 anos da assistência e
para trazer o bem estar melhor
acho que muito vai ficar mais legal
também obrigado